jean is with us in Phoenix hi Jean
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how do
you how are you better than I deserve
what's up good it is how to question I
just recently lost my job and I have had
a judgment against me for an old credit
card debt that is extremely old and
they've added an interest and everything
to it and they're trying to collect
about $14,000 from me on this debt and
other than the state of Arizona that the
judgment is from another state in Las
Vegas and I have contacted lawyers I've
done consultation season everything
Arizona layers say I have to hire Nevada
layer when I talk about it layers they
say come in Arizona they can't help me
so I'm just kind of stuck and I'm not
sure what to do and how I can get rid of
this stuff okay
what was the original amount you
borrowed it was off of the Discover
credit card in their original amount
that I owed on it was somewhere between
two to three thousand dollars and it's
escalated to 14,000 over a number of
years with legal fees and so forth
correct you have any money
I just might talk they don't okay so
it's not relevant today you can't do
anything about it anyway right okay so
when you get another job your first goal
is going to be or one of your goals is
going to be to save up $2,000 and then I
want you to just call the law firm and
begin to negotiate with them the
original amount I owed you guys owed
discover was $2,000 I'm broke I have no
money I'm single I make no money you do
not give them any information about
where you are what state you're in you
don't tell them where you work you don't
tell them anything okay
does it alone I never did before and
they just started garnishing my wages
from my other job and then my main
concern is that this also has never been
on my credit doesn't I have I have
really good credit and I don't matter
right that's not relevant what's
relevant is is this is screwing up your
life your credit is way down the list of
things to worry about we got to get this
thing out of your life
so you begin at $2,000 they're not going
to take it when you call them but you're
going to make them that offer and you're
going to begin to negotiate and you're
just going to cry poor mouth is what we
call it you know what that means no when
you say your poor mouth means you talk
about how poor you are okay and how you
got no money and how you can't I don't
have any money and I can't pay you all
I've gots this $2,000 and that's what I
owed you guys originally I've got that
saved up I can give you that as
settlement in full you understand what I
mean that they accept that as settlement
and the whole debt goes away they accept
the two thousand and then if they don't
take it just keep saving money and
they're not going to take it you're
going to keep talking to them every so
often not ten times a day not ten times
a week once every two weeks you have a
discussion with them okay and you
continue to negotiate with them and
continue to tell them how poor and how
broke you are and then when you get up
to 2,500 you say you know I've save
another five hundred I can give you that
well send us that and then we'll do
payments no my financial coach told me
not to do anything with you unless three
things happen one is that I settled it
in a lump sum if you got a pencil uh-huh
write this down
you have to settle it in a lump sum no
payments number two
you have to get the agreement in writing
from them so they have to send you an
email or a letter okay so that you've
keep talking to them keep talking to
them finally you've saved up two
thousand three thousand and whatever is
finally you talk them into taking that
as a lump sum settlement in full
reference point number one and reference
point number two is then they send you
an email or a letter saying we will
accept that amount of money whatever it
is twenty-five hundred dollars by such
and such a date yeah settlement in full
on this account and it makes the account
go away completely you following me yes
the third item there's three things you
have to write down the third one is do
not allow them to have electronic access
to your checking account is they'll want
a SAP your checking account for the
money and that's not possible it's not
in my checking account it's in a shoebox
in my living room I don't have it I
don't have a checking account I can't
let you because if you give them
electronic access to your checking
account they'll clean you
out because they lie great yes law firms
lie I know it's shocking but they do and
so you have to you have to maintain the
stiff-armed approach where you keep them
at bay you don't let the dog get close
enough to you to bite you you following
me yes okay now then what you do is you
send them a money order or you send them
a wire with a Western Union or whatever
after you get it in writing if you give
them money before you get it in writing
you will have to start the whole process
over again because they'll act like
nothing ever happened they'd like they
had no agreement with you mm-hmm
and we don't want to start over do we
know okay so you got to be a lot tougher
than you sound on the phone right now
okay can you get tough yes okay you got
a tough side right I do okay roll out
your playground tough side you got to
hit back now okay but you save up 2,000
bucks when you get your stuff going get
the process started somewhere two three
four thousand dollars they're going to
accept it if you keep beating on them
and convincing them how poor you are
because you're not rich are you no okay
then tell the truth no I'm not I don't
like anything just lost my job but don't
give them information about how to find
you and track you down and garnish your
wages again make it hard for them that's
the idea this is the Dave Ramsey show
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others
Oh